[Music]
Bud Light referred beverage at sporting
events concerts and todrey burlesque
shows from a man who places electrical
tape over his nipples perfect beer for
blowing out the
[Music]
pipes hello Internet I'm Dave Rubin this
is the Ruben report it's December 13th
2023 we're live streaming on Rumble
locals and YouTube Share subscribe tap
that notification Bell if you haven't
and join us for our postgame show where
you can comment you can question you can
poke me whatever you want to do well not
poke me different show Ruben report.
locals.com our merch store is all new
and all fancy and ready for you for the
holidays dve ruin. store if you want
some hoodies if you want some caps if
you want some mugs and all sorts of
other stuff and let's just dive right
into it today I think it is time to say
no we have got to stand our ground
everyone knows there's a lot of
craziness out there and today I've got
to call some balls and Strikes kind of
on my own side and with some people that
I know with some people that I like but
as I always say on the show all I can do
is tell you what I think and let the
chips fall where they may and sometimes
people will like me for it and sometimes
they won't but I had friends before I
got into this and I'm pretty sure I'll
have friends after so I think we're
going to be okay but the point is that
for those of you that that are not woke
basically at this point it's kind of
everyone versus the woke at least at the
moment so for those of us who agree on a
whole bunch of the uh issues the 5%
let's say that we disagree on or even
the 10% that we disagree on whatever
that is uh that percentage right there
could actually be the percentage that
determines whether we beat these people
or not because when we get wins whether
we agree on every little thing related
to taxes or abortion or really closely
held things whether we agree on all that
or not when we get wins we really got to
like hold those wins and look at the
wins and examine the wins and go like oh
we got a win let's acknowledge the win
let's see how we can replicate that but
what you don't want to do is is snatch
Victory away you don't want to snatch
defeat from the jaws of Victory right
you don't want to just be getting wins
and then be like oh we got so close
let's let's reverse that and that seems
to be what H what's happening with a
bunch of people right now the reason we
did that budlight cold open uh is that
as you guys know a couple months back
Dylan Mulaney this dude
who puts on a dress and it's unclear if
he or she had all the surgeries it
doesn't even matter calls himself uh
well wait he he he's Dylan mulany he
calls himself what what's what's the
woman's name d m no but but what's the
girl's name he call he's a girl now and
in his mind wait he switched over they
never switched the name
yeah jeez come on gal well anyway so
Dylan Mulaney who I guess never even I
guess I never even put that together
that's how stupid the whole thing is so
Dylan Mulaney was a dude who was an
actor decides to become quote unquote a
woman right uh then he was in The Book
of Mormon like he was he was somewhat of
a legit Broadway actor I guess at at
some level you know the story becomes a
woman but also becomes like the worst
sort of over-the-top stereotype of a
woman uh and then gets this strange
partnership this sponsorship deal with
budlight a whole bunch of people wake up
to it and Bud Light subsequently gets a
massive ground up right Grassroots
boycott and people are just like hey
there's a whole bunch of other beers out
there we don't need to support a beer
that is not in line with our values
that's actually a beautiful thing as
opposed to sort of top down cancel
culture where we find one random person
who you never heard of before who works
at a company that you probably never
bought a product from and you're really
pissed about something and you try to
destroy a whole bunch of people for that
that's the bad kind the good kind is a
bunch of people being like all right
I've decided where I'm going to spend my
dollars and in a capitalist Society
where there's a whole bunch of beers out
there pretty sure there's more than 10
10 beers when you go to the Beer section
uh it is a good thing when you use your
dollars with companies that are in line
with your value so I want to start uh
first well the backdrop of all of this
is that you may have heard about this
over the last couple days Tucker Carlson
who of course left Fox News or Fox News
left him there's a lawsuit related to
all of that uh he started launching his
show on x/ Twitter he has now announced
that he is launching TC
n which sounds like a country Channel
but it is the Tucker Carlson Network
apparently he's going to have a bunch of
shows I don't know that they've laid out
the Full Slate yet maybe he'll bring in
some other people we'll see about that
uh but anyway he had UFC president Dana
White on and apparently Dana White and
the UFC are now partnering with Bud
Light and that might seem a little odd
to you we've played a lot of clips of
Dana White he he hates the mainstream
media he has you know said f you to
sponsors that are not in line with his
values and everything else anyway he sat
down with Tucker and Tucker asked him
about how he could be partnering with
but line tell you what if you consider
yourself a patriot right you're a
patriot you should be drinking gallons
of Bud Light believe me when I tell you
wait wait wait I should be boycot I
should be boycotting budlight Gall
gallons of budlight you should have
budlight drums stacked up in your garage
and drinking it right out of the keg
they are way more aligned with you than
most of these other beer companies are
are that I guarantee you take it from
somebody who's in the know who does
business with beer companies you are way
more aligned with Bud Light than you are
with any I mean they didn't come into
partnership with you by accident no
obviously we had multiple bids on the
table seek you out we had multiple
biders on the table they were one of
them and as I you know history has shown
me with relationships that I've had with
other beer companies I who lean more
this way yeah I who consider myself a
patriot I don't go crazy over the whole
Patriot thing but I consider myself a
proud American I'm happy to be an
American I love this country and you are
way more aligned with anheiser bush than
you are with other beer companies okay
so I just want to reiterate something on
on a whole as a whole I don't know Dana
White personally I'd be happy to sit
down with him I think there's something
interesting going on in that whole UFC
world it's not totally my thing but the
reason I've played a whole bunch of
clips from him is I find it cool when
someone who is not really in politics or
anything like that starts getting into
this culture war and kind of doing the
right things and we've played a clip you
may remember a clip from about a month
ago where we played a clip of uh Dana
White on Theo Van's podcast where Theo
Von said that there was a sponsor that
didn't want him to air an episode where
Theo uh interviewed Robert F Kennedy Jr
and Dana White was like well who is the
sponsor and theovon found out it was
pelaton and the and then Dana White was
like all right we're not going to uh
work with pelaton anymore so there's an
interesting thing here on one hand he's
kind of doing the right thing there what
he's telling you is that everyone should
be drinking gallons above light now look
regardless of whether you're a uh a
patriot super
Patriot a regular Patriot or a half a
patriot nobody should be drinking
gallons of Bud Light right like you
shouldn't drink a ton of beer in general
now I happen to be a tequila guy and
people say Dave you you've lost a little
weight over the last couple months how
you do it well I cut back on drinking a
bit I was never drinking a crazy amount
certainly during the week drink a little
more on the weekends but also tequila
you could just sip a little bit by the
way Dave rubin's coming out with his own
tequila we'll have more on that in the
new year but tequila you could just sip
a little bit and you're G to get less
calories you get a nice effect blah blah
blah no one should be drinking gallons
of it but but all right putting that
aside it's just that he's being a little
over the top there he keeps saying that
that Bud Light is more in line with your
values but he never lays out what that
means how is Bud Light more in line with
your values than these other but uh
companies I think what he's trying to
say and again I'm not trying to crush
this guy or tell you he's evil or
anything else but but in essence what
he's saying is budlight gave us a
ton of money they gave us an awful lot
of money and here I am telling you to
drink gallons of it and that they're in
line with your values I'm not going to
explain that or how other beer companies
aren't in line with your values but they
did give me an awful lot of
money anyway I want to steal man Dana
White's argument and be fair to him I
really do so here's a little more uh
detailed reasoning uh that he laid out
on why he went with budlight this is
actually also from the theovon podcast
take a look is it hard for you guys to
pick sponsors I know you guys have a new
sponsorship you guys have new
sponsorship with Bud Light right yep but
is it do people like do companies come
and do like shark tank for you kind of
to present the brand or like kind yeah
kind of so um you know the UFC is at a
point now where you know guys come to us
and and and want to pitch their their
brands or whatever it is to to uh
advertise with us
and recently you know I I've become very
involved in the uh on the sponsorship
side so I'm at a point now where in my
life in my career I want to be with
people that I'm aligned with people that
you know yeah it's it's not it's not
just about the money it's like this
whole BD light deal you know people are
talking now sellout and all this
they say believe me I'm the furthest
thing from a sellout yeah Bud Light is
the right move for me they're exactly
who I want to be with right now and uh
we are very aligned as far as core
values go you know what I mean 65,000
Americans they employ yeah that right
there should be enough 65,000 Americans
are employed there why would you want to
put a bullet in that brand off of one
thing how about you go back and look at
all the good things they've done yeah
right a good point and where they really
stand and what they really believe in
they take care of veterans they they
they take care of veterans families and
First Responders families who have
fallen and the list just goes on and on
almost a billion dollars a year with us
Farmers wow that alone is the reason you
should be drinking Bud Light yeah so I I
look deeper than just right you know oh
they did this can with whoever I give a
sh about that all right hold on none of
those are reasons you should be drinking
Bud Light if you like beer and you like
the taste of Bud Light which Conor
you're you're the beer guy here like
where do you put but it's not you're
shaking your head no it's not in the top
yeah I suppose that's why you would
drink Bud Light that's why you choose
any any coffee that you like or any
juice that you like or club soda or
anything that you drink any bottle of
water they all taste the same you choose
one because you like the brand or the
the you like the bottle you like
whatever okay fine you like the story
behind it um but there there's a couple
things there first off he obviously Took
a ton of money from them okay fine that
that's just fine people do business I
don't begrudge anyone uh operating
within the capitalist system I also want
to say real quick that there's a reason
I'm doing all of this I'm not I'm not
trying to add fuel to the fire over the
budlight controversy but I'm trying to
connect this to the much wider thing
that I mentioned up top about the
culture wars and how you get wins and
then how the system can sort of take
those wins away from you and that's what
it seems like is happening right here as
they're trying to like make it seem like
you'll be patriotic by drinking Bud
Light look there's something about 6 all
right so they employ 65 5,000 people and
you don't want those people to suffer of
course you don't actually when the
budlight boycott happened we played a
video of a guy who was just like a local
distributor in a in a store saying hey
nobody's buying Bud Light anymore my job
is in trouble now of course you have
sympathy for those people for sure but
there's tons of other beer companies
that if budlight if there's a boycott
against budlight because people have had
it with the woke garbage that they
pushed in and literally at an executive
saying we don't really like the Frat
guys who are drinking our beer we want
to be a beer for other people well then
the people who would eventually lose
their jobs through that boycott will get
jobs at other beer companies also just
the idea that you shouldn't boycott a
company because they have a lot of
employees the government has 2 million
employees right like so something is not
good inherently because it has a lot of
employees um again the thing about
veterans like that's all nice but at the
end of the day this is really like you
got a bunch of money and you're singing
a different tune and and that just kind
of is Megan Kelly had a nice tweet about
this because I think it gets to the
heart of it because there was a way that
they could have maybe extricated
themselves from this a little more
cleanly uh she said budlight never
apologized or even acknowledged How
Deeply it offended its customers that's
because it's still beholden to the
vicious trans activists who threatened
it and cares more about them than its
customers why would you give them your
business because one musician folded
hard no the funny thing is I kid you not
I have not seen anyone drink Bud Light
anywhere at one bar or restaurant or
anywhere else since this whole thing has
happened so the point is had they
apologized really apologized really
Backtrack on something really said we're
going to go into our corporate structure
and try to make some sense of this and
figure out what happened because you
guys know I mean look what look at the
stories that we've told you the last
couple days about Harvard and Penn and
what you see happening all over the
world right now in terms of the wrong
ideas getting institu into institutions
and then what that does it's like you
don't owe budlight anything because
they're a big beer company like I've
been to anheiser I was at Bush Gardens
when I was a kid saw the Clydesdales
great horses I don't want them to suffer
but that's not a reason to drink Bud
Light right it's just not um or I think
perhaps maybe what Dana could have done
is say okay you know what you guys are
offering like they must have offered him
a crazy amount of money I I have no man
no idea they at one point it said they
were going to Triple their marketing
budget let's say they offered him 50
million bucks I I don't know what the
number is I'm completely making that out
of th air he could have said to them all
right you want me to put my reputation
on the line uh I'll take your cash
that's pretty good and I can do good
things with that cash and build my brand
and all that stuff and everything else
uh but you're going to have to apologize
first you're going to have to have a
forthright apology you're going to have
to sit down on my show and explain
yourselves but they didn't do any of
that and that's what kind of gets us
back into the muck and the Meer I would
say and and sort of this unclear place
of oh we got an organic win we actually
did it we we're always trying to figure
out how do you win in this culture War
budlight started losing it sent a
message to Corporate America and now
Corporate America through cash is taking
that win away from us so I will let I
will remind you in just a moment of what
budlight actually did and then we're
going to connect it to a bunch of wider
stuff because this is much bigger than
just about crappy beer that I used to
drink upside down from a keg when I was
in college cuz I was a pretty cool dude
but before we get to that let's talk
about gravity to Fire Shoes you ever do
that have so them lift you up in college
and then what do they call that what a
keg stand I used to do that Jesus it's a
miracle I'm still here anyway let's talk
about gravity to fire shoes for a minute
uh I want to talk to you about something
that's been making my days a whole lot
easier and I'm pretty sure it has
nothing to do with transactivism that's
right I'm talking about gravity to Fire
Shoes these shoes are something else
guys I mean I'm a fan of comfortable
Footwear everybody knows that but these
shoes take it to a whole new level more
than just shoes they're basically clouds
for your feet I'm not kidding in a
double blind study by Olive View UCLA
Medical Center and published in the
Journal of the American podiatric
Medical Association participants
experience 85% less knee pain it's the
most powerful shock absorption system
put into a shoe gravity def fire has
patented versos shck technology it's
like a mini trampoline in your shoes
whether strolling through the park
running errands or even just lounging at
home these shoes have got your back or I
should say your feet even better they're
stylish you get both comfort and style
that look good and feel great so here's
the deal gravity to fire is offering
limited exclusive holiday time deal just
head over to
gy.com
gd.com use promo code 30 you're going to
get an extra 30% off your order that's
an amazing 30% off for being here today
it's a holiday thank you gift from
Gravity to fire why not treat your feet
to some well-deserved comfort gdf y.com
promo code 30 for 30% off your order and
now back to me and I promise you good
people If gravity defire tomorrow offers
a sponsorship to Dylan Mulaney I will
not work for them and if they came in
here and then suddenly I was like oh I
love Dylan mulany isn't he and or she
wonderful in her gravity to fire shoes
and I was doing that you might think
Dave how much did they pay you to say
that so I think you get the point anyway
what led to all of this well you might
remember this budlight uh VP of
marketing Alysa hiners shy explaining
her decision to go oak I'm a
businesswoman I had a really clear job
to do when I took over budlight and it
was this brand is in Decline it's been
in Decline for a really long time and if
we do not attract young drinkers to come
and drink this brand there will be no
future for budlight so I had this super
a clear mandate it's like we need to
evolve and Elevate this incredibly
iconic brand and my what I brought to
that was a belief in okay what is what
do what does evolve and elevate mean it
means inclusivity it means Shifting the
tone it means having a campaign that's
truly inclusive and feels lighter and
brighter and different and appeals to
women and to men and representation is
it sort of the heart of evolution you've
got to see people who reflect you in the
work and we had this hangover I mean
budlight had been kind of a brand of
fratty kind of outof touch humor and it
was really important that we had another
approach it's so funny budlight has been
a brand of fratty outof touch humor it
also then became the biggest uh beer
brand in America certainly the biggest
light beer brand in America and nobody
had a problem with it and they were
making boatloads of money and frat guys
drink beer you know who doesn't really
generally drink beer trans women and
also as a g as a general rule trans
women whatever that is even is is such a
tiny a ridiculously tiny percentage of
the of the
population that it to Market to them
would be insane but also I'm going to go
to Connor on this one too or I'll go to
any of you guys when you're at on a
date if a girl you're sit down at the
restaurant right or you go to the bar
you're sitting at the bar you order
something and then the girl I mean
before this whole Bud Light thing if the
girl had said I'll have a Bud Light what
would you have thought of that girl red
flag right what do you want a girl to
drink what what's
gonna gin and tonic would be nice for a
chick what what would you want a girl to
drink red wine red wine would be nice
maybe a cosmo or something but like it's
not for girls it's not that a girl can't
drink Bud Light anyway you get it but
you see how I'm connecting this to
everything else once woke get in gets
into the system whether it is Harvard
and next thing you know they're calling
for genocide of Jews whether it's Bud
Light and they're instead of marketing
to frat guys they're trying to get
chicks to drink their shitty beer it
destroys absolutely everything so what
was the Genesis of all of this well here
is a portion of the budlight ad
featuring Dylan moany who I still can't
believe never changed his or her name
there was just no name change on this
thing take
hi impressive carrying skills right I
got some Bud Lights for us so I kept
hearing about this thing called March
Madness and I thought we were all just
having a hectic month but it turns out
it has something to do with sports and
I'm not sure exactly which sport but
either way it's a cause to
celebrate this month I celebrated my day
365 of Womanhood and budlight sent me
possibly the best gift ever a Kon with
my face on it check out my Instagram
story to see how you can enjoy March
Madness with Bud Light and maybe win
some money too love you cheers go team
whatever team you love I love too
okay love you okay break okay fine and
you subsequently remember everything
that happened since and again there were
some wins there were some actual wins
you might remember this this is Kid Rock
responding to Bud Light after that hole
ad whatever you want to call that
go grandpa is feeling a little frisky
today let me uh say something to all you
and be as clear and concise as
possible
light anheiser Bush have a terrific
day okay again I know this might seem
like a little inside baseball in the
World of Beer and the emotions that it
can cause all of us to have but there's
something interesting going on here as
Brock just mentioned just just what was
it two weeks ago when Trump walked out
at a UFC event with Dana White and
Tucker Carlson Kid Rock was with him too
so there's this strange thing where
these people are sort of taking every
side of everything instead of just
taking the win when you can get it but
that's how the system operates a lot of
cash I don't know what the cash
situation was I don't know and I guess
maybe I could get a call today and they
and budlight could be like Dave we'd
like you to help clean up the Bud Light
thing could you put on a dress for a 100
million bucks and guys we'd really have
to talk about it it
would anyway the boycott then happened
and again it was a groundup boycott
right and it was not aimed at any of the
employ employees of the company it was
just saying hey we've had it with this
and and there are literally there must
be literally thousands of beer brands in
the United States of America and you
have other choices so here's a little uh
bit of info on the numbers actually that
the boycott uh accomplished in the week
ending April 8th 2023 budlight had
reportedly experienced an 11% drop in
sales and 21% drop in the week ending
April 15 2023 as of May 1st 2023
budlight off premise sales had dropped
26% % since the start of the boycott at
a shareholder meeting on May 4th
anheiser Bush inbev CEO Michael duus
distan the company from belany saying
this was one can one influencer one post
and not a campaign ducerus also said
that the drop in sales would represent
about 1% of our overall Global volumes
for that period duer said the company
would increase support to wholesalers
and triple budl light's advertising
budget in attempt in an attempt to
recover lost sales the point is guys and
again I'm not a Beer Drinker so fine
everyone can make those choices for
themselves but we started getting some
winds and they seem like maybe they're
being pulled back a little bit now I
want to connect this to something else
that's happening oddly in the political
space and the culture wars and
everything you might have heard about
this little controversy coming out of
Iowa over the last couple days there was
a uh satanic altar placed in the Iowa
state capital uh let's show you the
image here the image uh is from Jack
pesobic that is a satanic alar okay and
that is the state capital and what Jack
wrote there and I've had Jack on the
show several times uh but this is going
to be a sort of similar theme to what we
just discussed with Dana White uh Jack
wrote this is what Kim Reynolds has
allowed to be installed in the Iowa
state capital it is a satanic alter and
Idol now it is a satanic Altar and Idol
uh but it has nothing to do with Kim
Reynolds and and there's a reason that
poic is going after Kim Reynolds I'll
explain that in a second it was
Community noted which is the
factchecking apparatus of Twitter as you
guys know the Iowa capital is controlled
by the Iowa legislature not Governor
Reynolds the department of
administrative Services manages access
for displays at the capital which are
open to anyone through an application
process and do not discriminate on the
basis of religion or ideology now there
is an absolute conversation to be had
about these types of satanic things
being put on public property right and
I'm I'm actually more on the side of
that they should not be there let's just
put that aside for just a second okay uh
it had nothing to do with Kim Reynolds
as the factchecking pointed out but
pesobic who is in Trump land wants to
hit Kim Reynolds because Kim Reynolds is
backing the santis right so it has
nothing to do with Kim Reynolds but
again this was really going after des
santis and actually you know who kind of
did the thing that caused it so that the
satanists could have their things in the
yeah it was trumped here's DeSantis last
night he did a town hall on CNN which a
Tapper so it's interesting I I I heard
this and then I was like well how did it
get there is that even a religion and
Loan behold the Trump
Administration gave them approval to be
under the IRS as a religion so that gave
them the legal ability to potentially do
it so I don't know what the legislature
what they how they analyzed it but if
very well may be because of that ruling
under Donald Trump that they may have
had a legal leg to stand up my view
would be that's that's not a religion
that the founding fathers were trying to
create um but I do think that IRS ruling
uh I was really surprised to see that
they did that okay all right so there's
a sort of similar theme here to the to
the opening of the show I'm not just
trying to attack people willy-nilly but
sometimes we get some winds on things
and and when we get wins on things we
have to take those wins but we also have
to to not make everything so political
that when a
satanic Monument shows up in the Iowa
state capital and you're like oh I can
get Kim Reynolds over that because the
guy I really want to get is D santis and
then of course it turns out that it was
the Trump IRS that made them you know a
quote unquote uh religious organization
to get that tax exemption and that's why
they are allowed there so you have to
call balls and Strikes even when they're
rough on your same side because that
again is what will help us beat the Real
Enemy so the 10% differences or whatever
you want to think those differences are
those things that's the space that we
got to operate in we got to kind of put
those aside and go for the Real Enemy
but also acknowledge let's not burn each
other down at the exact same time uh so
the big fight of course in the country
politically I would say at the moment at
least on the more conservative side is
what's going to happen uh with this
Trump disantis situation and you know
the people keep saying that that there's
Nikki Haley momentum I I don't really
see it it's just one of the things that
the media just keeps saying sort of like
polls here are polls you better believe
the polls or here's Nikki Haley momentum
you better believe that anyway I want to
show you one more video of the santis
last night uh with Jake Tapper on CNN
because he's clearly the only guy
actually trying to say I'm the
alternative to Trump if you think that
we need to get over that thing welcome
governor and first of all thank you for
your service as a veteran it's important
to recognize your service as an American
so thank you very much thank you why
should my employees trust you to return
us to the prosperity that they enjoyed
under President Trump well Tim thanks
for the question I hope your business is
doing well I know things are are tough
right now with a lot of things I think
you trust me for a couple reasons one if
you look at what we've done in Florida
our economy is ranked number one of all
50 states uh We've boomed like we've
never have even in the face of all the
inflation and the interest rates which
we have to obviously struggle with too
uh but our un employment rate is 60%
lower than States like California which
are peer States I'd also say this I
think the first three years of the Trump
Administration the econom is better than
it has been but that last year with
covid I think was mishandled
dramatically shutting down the country
was a huge mistake printing trillions
and trillions of dollars was a huge
mistake that set the foundation for the
inflation that we see granted Biden came
in and poured gas on the fire it was re
lless that he did trillions but if you
look you have trillions and trillions of
dollars of course you're paying more for
that you're going to have inflation when
that happens look it's it's just true
again and this is where I cannot be
captured by my audience and I see
comments and I see people being pissed
at me and I also I you know like I can
see all that I can see all that but I
all I can do is tell you what is true
and the the beauty of backing the santis
I would say is that it doesn't tie me
into a pretzel every week like he just
that is true like it was a mistake to
shut down the country and even As Trump
was leaving office he was still trying
to get Dan santis to shut down Florida
everyone with their head on straight
knows that Florida is now the model for
whatever America can be if it if America
is going to succeed right and we know
that our unemployment is low and that we
have law in order on the streets and
that people are still moving here and
he's also acknowledging that yeah we've
got we've got some problems like
interest rates are high I can't deal
only with that right we're not we're not
an island in and of ourself just yet so
the point is there is a better way I
think there's a way that gets us out of
the drama that gets us out of the
grifting and the selling out and
everything else again we we will choose
which way to go and if it doesn't go the
way I want I'll be here the next day and
I'll be talking about that and that's
that too I want to show you one other
clip of Dan santis uh because uh here he
is on AIT this is a different thing this
is from PBS just a day or two ago
explaining how uh he will operate and
and not necessarily do things exactly
how Trump did them as a republican I
want everybody to do well it's not just
about who endorses me or who doesn't
there are people in this race that
haven't endorse me I'm not going to go
out and trash good Republicans just
because they have it endorsed me so I
think the way that Donald Trump has
handled that that that is not going to
work for this party uh to say that
unless you kiss his ring then somehow
you're not so aren't we all kind of over
it aren't we all kind of over all of the
infighting and constantly trying to
destroy each other and this one who
worked for me is a and that one
who worked for me is an idiot and he's a
sellout and he like aren't we over it
don't we all want something a little bit
better don't we want something a little
bit younger I mean Bill Burr who I think
is still basically a lefty I played the
clip of him yesterday being like
shouldn't it be a guy who's in his 40s
with a little skin in the game because
he's going to have to live through all
of the policies so we we will decide if
we want that as a country and first it
we have to get through the primary so
first it's up to more let's say
republican or conservative leaning
people but again you have to call those
balls and Strikes like it's all you can
do it's the only way I would be able to
live with myself and do this show but I
think there's something else because
intrinsically telling the truth is the
right thing to do right we all know that
like telling the truth is the right
thing to do but then there's another
reason and it's instrumentally if you
tell the truth you can actually win I
don't think by lying you can win over
time you might get some wins here and
there but you will not win over time but
if you tell the truth and and you do it
if you no if you do it honestly if you
tell the truth and you do it earnestly
you will get long-term wins and now I
want to connect budlight to some of the
other things going on in the world
because there still is this Ukraine
thing and we have not been talking about
it too much lately obviously everything
going on between Israel and Gaza has
kind of sidelined us on the on the
Foreign Affairs part of that uh but
zalinski showed up in DC yesterday and
he wants some cash and uh here he is at
a press conference with Joe Biden and
listen to Joe Biden's little Freudian
slip here uh this one this one's a doozy
they understand as I do the Ukraine's
success and its ability to deter
aggression in the future are vital to
security for the World At Large and I
have repeatedly made clear from our
first day in office we also need Ukraine
to make changes to fix the broken
immigration system here we also need
Congress to make the changes to fix the
broken immigration system here at home
my team is working with Senate Democrats
and Republicans to try to find a
bipartisan compromise both in terms of
changes in policy and provide the
resources we need to secure the Border
compromise is how democracy works and
I'm ready and offered compromise already
holding Ukraine funding hostage in the
attempt to force through an extreme
Republican partisan agenda on the border
is not how it works we need real
solutions it may not be how it works Joe
but it is how it should work what does
Ukraine
funding we can all have our feelings
about that what does Ukraine funding
have to do with defending our border if
we cannot defend our border why should
we be giving money to Ukraine when on
top of everything else it is very
unclear what the mission is it is very
unclear what a win would be and a whole
bunch of other things right like yeah
like do you but this is how the
government operates uh Biden then did
announce that he was through the stroke
of a pen giving another 200 million in
apartment to Ukraine but he doesn't have
unlimited power through stroke of the
pen so Mike Johnson who of course is the
new house leader at least for now
because that Republican majority is
getting Slimmer and Slimmer and we know
that now that Kevin McCarthy is going to
step down and I think there's a guy in
Ohio a republican who's about to go work
at a college instead so the Republicans
will in essence have a one seat lead
when you know somebody's going to fall
down the stairs and then we get hakee
Jeff and the Democrats run the show but
let's hold that for now uh but here's
Mike Johnson after meeting with zalinski
saying that Ukraine funding has to be
tied to border security meaning if we're
going to give you some freaking money uh
how about we can actually do a little
something for the citizens of America
how novel we need a clear articulation
of the strategy to allow Ukraine to win
and thus far their responses have been
insufficient they have not provided us
the clarity and the detail that we have
requested over and over since literally
24 hours after I was handed the gavl as
Speaker of the House and so what the
Biden Administration seems to be asking
for is billions of additional dollars
with no appropriate oversight no clear
strategy to win and and none of the
answers that I think the American people
are owed I have also also made very
clear from day one that our first
condition on any National Security
Supplemental spending package is about
our own National Security First the
border is an absolute catastrophe and
this is because of the policies of this
white house and this Administration you
really need to think about this and it
it does maybe you're watching this and
I'm a little more isolationist on
Ukraine and again I just think that that
from the beginning you've seen what I've
said about this there was mission creep
we don't know who the good guys and bad
guys are as I've talked about many times
I had Ram paen we don't know where the
money's going like there it's just like
Putin's got nukes like there's a whole
bunch of series of problems there by the
way I would say that's starkly different
than what's going on with Israel and
Gaza because there's a very clear wind
there which is the toppling of uh Hamas
and then actually setting a border and
helping an ally who helps us with
technology and all sorts of stuff but
that that's that's a complete aside um
but he's basically making two clear
points could you tell us what the plan
is if we're going to give them billions
of dollars that's number one and how
about we do a little something at home
first how many of those videos do we
play each week where we just have people
pouring through our border no one that
could even approximately consider
themselves pro- America could think that
that's okay the Democrat Party thinks
it's okay and the people of CNN and
MSNBC think it's okay because I don't
think they're very Pro America that's
kind of where we're at at the moment I
want to show you one other clip on this
uh Senator JD V from Ohio was on Fox
talking to Laura Ingram about a pause in
Ukraine funding and how I don't know
maybe we could do a little something in
America for Americans we learned this
weekend that we are funding
oneir of Ukraine's government that
includes teacher salaries janitor
salaries everybody's not just the
military everybody's salaries are funded
by the us taxpayers as the people in our
country are deciding between food or
medicine right now people in Ohio can't
afford food young people can't afford to
buy homes we're paying for their
government you're exactly right we've
got to focus on our own problems and
Laura the the thing that is in our best
interest is to get the killing to stop
that's what we should be doing with
American leadership not writing more
blank checks to endless go lecture uh
lecture Europe lecture Europe put his
hand out to Europe see how far again
it's not the most riveting clip it's
just true it's just true how about we
deal with some of our problems here as
lawyers lying out how about we deal with
problems related to prices of food and
things of that nature but B inflation
has caused you know you print money
money becomes worth less food and
everybody wants more of the money
because it's worth less that's that's
how it Cascades throughout the system
and of course JD is right on that we
don't we just don't know what the high
hell is going on there the point of all
this which will get us to the end of the
show is that positive results will
actually arise when you begin to say no
to the things that you know to be wrong
right Ukraine whatever is going on there
and this desire for the machine to
connect it to our border it's wrong Bud
Light suddenly making a comeback because
they've got enough cash to buy out
people it's kind of wrong blaming Kim
Reynolds because you really want to get
to santis over something when you know
it's actually Trump who did the original
thing with the IRS it's wrong and we've
got to get through this fog of lies and
if you get through the fog of Lies then
you will find that other good people
will stand up and you will build better
things one of the guys who's built
better things is Dave pornoy over at bar
stool Sports uh Dave I is he a graduate
of Harvard or he's from Boston area he
went to right he went to Michigan but he
is uh you know he's largely in the
Boston area now big Sports guy he
created bar stol sports right so I'm
guessing Dave por I probably was growing
up wanted to be part of ESPN ESPN goes
woke he creates his own thing he it is
absolutely massive uh and he's had it
with Harvard too uh here he is on Fox
Business explaining his hiring policies
going forward you will not hire anyone
from Harvard until the school's Deans
step down I think a lot of leaders have
to do it it was disgusting what those uh
Deans and presidents did under oath uh
makes no sense to me I don't know how if
you can't condemn genocide I don't care
whether we're talking Jews Muslims any
group of people then you don't deserve
to be you know in a position of power
you got to get out what about Free
Speech does that come into this yeah
listen
um is Hitler allowed to say I want to
kill the Jews I want to kill the Jews I
want to kill the Jews right up till he
kills the Jews uh I I would say no and
when you're endangering people and
causing harm I think you got to put a
stop to it it's called common isn't it
interesting again I take I like these
videos of people that have that really
never would have thought they would be
in these fights whether it is Dana White
when I'm praising him or whether it's uh
poroy right now like these people who
suddenly can make more as he just said
Common Sense than than the people who
were supposed to be our sens makers
Brock just pointed out to me actually
that bar stool Sports was part of ESPN
and ESPN got rid of it because they were
kind of twoo edgy they weren't going
along the woke lines that even I didn't
even realize that that proves my point
even further and now he's built
something that is growing exponentially
and ESPN is having all sorts of problems
so the point ladies and gentlemen of
today's show if you don't back down if
you do the right thing for the right
thing sake you might actually Force
change for good how do I know it well
Liz McGill from upen has resigned yes
that's right I don't need to read the
whole thing to you but after that
absolutely horrific Congressional
hearing where she could not condemn
calling for genocide of Jews and again
as Porto points out it wouldn't matter
if you were calling for genocide of
Muslims if you're calling for genocide
of white people that would be just as
bad uh now she is gone and she did it
while smiling the entire time which was
really particularly disgusting we will
find out more about Claud and gay over
at Harvard Harvard's backing her right
now but now it's coming out that she we
covered this yesterday she plagiarized
on her dissertation and you can just
sense like that thing is just going to
keep burning over there but I said it
yesterday and I meet it again por nois
saying he's not going to hire a Harvard
grad I'm just not hiring College grads
anymore if you do not go to college if
you have virtually no education we want
you here at the Reuben report okay if
you have no idea what you're doing if
you've never been to a school you don't
know the difference between a pencil and
a pen we want you on the team resume at
Ruben report
uh guys budlight days are probably
numbered but only if enough people are
like oh we just we'll take the W right
sometimes they tell you take the L how
about we take the W for a change
wouldn't that be something I think it
would be feel very satisfied with
today's
show okay people of the internet is live
at 1M uh we have a new Twitter account
as we've mentioned before Ruben report
show on the Twitter thex if you have not
subscribed please please do on
rumble.com rubben report postgame show
coming up right now Ruben report.
locals.com and we leave you with one of
the members of the Hamas caucus with
uttering complete nonsense as
always and so they go out and they need
to feed their child and they don't have
money so you maybe have to they're put
in a position where they feel like they
either need to shoplift some bread or go
hungry that
night
[Music]